[Musique]
bonsoir et bienvenue dans ce set 8
litres d'eau durant cette émission nous
reviendrons sur l'actualité de la
semaine dans les yvelines
le sommaire de ce vendredi 20 septembre
la république en marche a dévoilé hier
de nouvelles investiture et soutien de
46 nouveaux candidats pour les élections
municipales
cinq sont dans les yvelines ou pour le
pont avec pierre-luc référent et les
rênes du 78 jeudi soir a débuté le 1er
réole facturé festival de monte la jolie
un événement qui met les cuivres aux
éléphants à l'honneur et qui se poursuit
jusqu'à dimanche
pour l'occasion nous avons pu visiter
les deux grandes manufactures voisine
semaine européenne de la mobilité
manifestation des pompiers à versailles
mobilisation citoyenne pour
l'environnement nous ferons comme chaque
semaine le tour de l'actualité des
derniers jours
[Musique]
les halls factory festival c'est en ce
moment à mantes-la-jolie l'événement
musical regroupe des artistes de jazz et
de classique
l'occasion de découvrir deux
manufactures située à mantes la ville
l'une est spécialisé dans la création de
saxophones l'autre dans la clarinette un
récit de maxime abolin avec la voix
d'aurélie ronde
ce sont deux manufactures de renommée
mondiale buffet crampon et henri selmer
sont pourtant situé à quelques mètres
l'une de l'autre
la première est leader mondial dans la
fabrication de clarinette
la seconde est une référence dans la
création de saxophone
les deux établissements ont ouvert leurs
portes à l'occasion de l'eole factory
festival pour la première édition du all
factory festival on a travaillé
conjointement pour pouvoir essayer
d'ouvrir ses grandes manufactures au
public et aussi parce qu'on est bien ce
week-end batman comme errol factory
travailler autour de tout ce qui est un
instrument à vent et patrimoine musical
du territoire ça nous semblait très
important de pouvoir coupler une visite
plus des manufactures avec le début du
festival
grâce à ces portes ouvertes le public a
pu découvrir le travail minutieux des
employés ils sont 500 à travailler henry
selmer et 200 ch et buffet crampon
alors là exactement dans quel sens prend
de passer à lui
mes cordes on chantera de polir
l'intérieur du bois pour que l'eau et
l'air circule au maximum et plus droit
possible pour que tous puissent évacuer
pour que le son ne soit pas perturbé pas
qu'il y ait de quoi que
sonore pour les musiciens nous avons un
éclaté de saxophones c'est à dire toutes
les pièces qu'ils représentent et
mentale saxophone qui sont fixés sur un
cadre c'est pour éventuellement bien
montrer aux gens toutes les pièces qui
sont sur un instrument l'occasion aussi
pour les artistes de pouvoir découvrir
comment leurs instruments sont fabriqués
je ne savais pas du tout comment les
saxophones et est fabriqué j'ai déjà
fait réparer mon saxo à de nombreuses
reprises mais je n'ai jamais vu ça c'est
vraiment cool
les deux manufactures sont implantés à
mantes la ville depuis 1850 pour buffet
crampon et 1919 pour henri salvayre
[Musique]
pierre lux vous êtes avec nous et avec
nous bonjour bonjour vous êtes référent
yvelines de la république en marche
lrm qui a annoncé hier investir et
soutenir 46 nouveaux candidats pour les
élections municipales b 15 et 22 mars
2020 parmi eux cinq sont dans les
yvelines ce qui porte à 10 le nombre de
candidats vous les voyez s'afficher 6
investis dont gilles schmidt à
rambouillet et 4 soutenue dont arnaud
péricard à saint germain en laye où le
rappel en candidat investi se présente
sous la bannière lrm alors comme
candidat soutenu porte une autre
étiquette mais ne verra pas de candidat
elle run en face il a le soutien du
parti
on va regarder plus attentivement saint
germain en laye une ville qui votent
historiquement à droite lors des
municipales 1977 michel péricard père de
l'actuel maire est élu avec l'étiquette
rpr
emmanuel lamy ump est ensuite élu en
1999 à son décès arnaud péricard le fils
donc de michel péricard est élu
républicain elle est aujourd'hui
apparentés divers droite pierre juste le
soutien à arnaud péricard c'est une
prise de risque limitée pour la
république en marche
salut toute élection et une prise de
risque nous avons tous regardé les
personnes les projets qui portent et
pour nous était naturel de soutenir
arnaud péricard qui a fait de sa ville
qui d'ailleurs ville qui a très
largement voté pour à cliquer en marche
au dernier scrutin
c'est une ville un peu un peu modèle
qu'on exactement une gouvernance qu'on
aimerait voir dans beaucoup de villes
pour le c'est naturel de le soutenir
arnaud péricard qui est bien installée
quand même dans cette ville le nom
péricard porte c'est soit il s'est fait
sur des convictions ou sur un certain
opportunisme
c'est assez curieux en fait quoi quand
on choisit un candidat qu'on avait ce
qui face à quelqu'un de bien installer
on prend des risques
sinon c'est d'opportunisme dans le x
s'est fait sur la conviction que qui
portait le meilleur le meilleur projet
pour la ville où une question mais non
concernant fois ci le maire karl olive
comme arnaud péricard a souvent affiché
un soutien à une aile macron membres de
l air il a rendu sa carte il aurait le
soutien
dès lors m karl olive pour l'instant la
situation un postier pas absolument pas
tranchée
on n'a pas aussi non plus de demandes de
soutien de karl olive donc ces problèmes
en une ville sur laquelle on aura une
décision qui sera prise dans les mois à
venir qui ne vend pas que deux quarts
livres mais aussi du projet qui se
porter des choses que l'on peut faire
soigner peut-être difficile d'autant
plus que nathalie martin
l'ancienne collaboratrice parlementaire
de la députée lrm florence granger a
annoncé se présenter contre lui avec la
liste précédemment sans étiquette et
elle elle pourrait être soutenu je ne
pense pas enfin on va s'attarder sur
rambouillet maintenant terre d'ancrage
de l'actuel président du sénat y
figurent des républicains gérard larcher
il en a été maire de 1983 à 2004
aujourd'hui c'est marc robert qui occupe
le poste sous l'étiquette l air au
printemps dernier son adjoint en charge
de l'emploi juge schmidt qui est
également suppléant de la députée aurore
bergé a quitté la majorité en expliquant
qu'il voulait se rapprocher
lrm il a été le premier candidat des
événements obtenir l'investiture en juin
dernier
encore un bastion de la droite
stratégique a décroché pour la
république en marche
c'est effectivement une ville importante
c'est plus haute ville du sud des
yvelines et c'est une ville qui l'a
aussi à montrer son attachement aux
valeurs aux élections européennes aux
élections législatives et aux élections
présidentielles et donc il était là
aussi un peu naturel pour nous présenter
un candidat quelques schmidt qui le
supplée en dehors depuis maintenant deux
ans c'était notre candidat idéal pour
nous représenter sur la ville on va
quitter les municipales pour
s'intéresser à la réforme des retraites
maintenant on en parlait dans cette
émission la semaine dernière la cgt
était à la rencontre des salariés ce
vendredi 20 septembre devant la gare de
saint quentin en yvelines
une action pour alerter sur les
problèmes des services publics et
préparer la journée de mobilisation du
24 septembre contre la réforme des
retraites
nicolas chabot et céline du moulin au
micro de rodolphe blondel on est dans le
cadre d'une campagne départementale
syndicales pour la défense des services
publics
en même temps on informe aussi sur les
retraites et la manifestation du 24
septembre
nous avons aussi dans la matinée était à
la rencontre des salariés des très
petites entreprises pour les informer de
leurs droits
alors certes encore très faible par
rapport à ce qu'ils paieront ce qu'on
peut trouver dans les grandes
entreprises mais néanmoins les droits
effectivement qui sont mis en place via
laisser perry qui représente les
salariés des tpe
pierre lui je me tourne vers vous une
première grève importante de la ratp on
l'a vu la cgt s'y prépare aussi les élus
locaux ils vont être mis à contribution
pour organiser des concertation
citoyenne dans le cadre de cette réforme
comment on établit ce dialogue est
d'avis que je pense d'abord en faisant
preuve d'une grande transparence sera la
fois la situation actuelle des retraites
qui est très peu lisible très peu
compréhensible par la majorité des
français des salariés qui ne comprennent
pas les différences tual existe entre
les régimes et et en plus cette
transparence je pense qu'il faut aussi
beaucoup d'ouverture il faut être à l
écoute de de ce que les français auront
à dire aussi bien les critiques que
évidemment les personnes qui seront
favorables
je pense le gouvernement l'a bien
compris le c'est un peu l'idée du
président de la république vers cette
démarche de concertation et simplement
commençons par la pédagogie pour bien
expliquer à son actuel et l'écoutent
pour recueillir les problèmes situations
individuelles qui qu'il faut pouvoir
évidemment un essai une écoute qui a été
fait avec le rapport de l'eau voit
justement ce rapport c'est celui ci qui
est contestée comment on fait pour
maintenir et continuer sur cette voie là
je pense pas qu'il soit contestée ni
dans son ensemble ni par l'ensemble des
français
je pense que il peut évoquer les
inquiétudes notamment fait les les
personnes qui bénéficient actuellement
de régimes spéciaux de retraite
c'est au gouvernement c'est aux élus
c'est à nous aussi en tant que parti
politique de rassurer sur ses
inquiétudes alors qu'hier nous vous
restez avec non pas ça l'essentiel de
l'actualité de la semaine
[Musique]
ils étaient environ 300 lundi matin
rassemblées devant le château de
versailles place d'armes
les sapeurs pompiers des yvelines ont
donné de la voix pour leurs
revendications la retraite les appels
bobologie les agressions mais surtout le
manque d'effectifs dans les camions
mathilde de deux minutes les a suivis en
tenue et armés de leurs banderoles et
sapeurs pompiers des yvelines se sont
donné rendez vous devant le château de
versailles
les mots d'ordre faire du bruit et
montré la présence des pompiers dans les
aujourd'hui l'objectif c'est de prendre
rendez-vous auprès des instances comme
le conseil départemental et la rs pour
les problèmes en liaison avec le samu 78
notamment afin de se faire entendre sur
les difficultés qui ont consulté un
quotidiennement
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
au son des gyrophares les pompiers se
rassemblent devant le conseil
départemental pour rencontrer une
délégation
une manifestation qui ne s'était pas
produit depuis 1999 et qui surprend les
passants j'ai vu mon manifestation est
juste et les pompiers
et comme
on est solidaire avec eux quand même ils
font des choses bien quand même ils ont
raison de manifester sur des choses qui
ne m'ont pas quand on a besoin d'eux
mais c'est qu'on appelle et pompiers ils
sont là voilà même cadre détendu
ravisseur l'a quand même c'est
fondamental d'avoir une caserne de
pompiers
ils rendent des services et imaginable
sauf qu'il faut qu'il soit un effectif
normal
à la sortie du conseil départemental les
représentants des syndicats annoncent 22
embauches en octobre et peut-être une
cinquantaine en début d'année prochaine
une déclaration qui va pas les sapeurs
plus tôt on nous dit à chaque fois qu'on
embauche 10 15 20 30 sapeurs-pompiers
enfin sauf qu'un a autant qui partent
d'année en année donc a la final le
bilan c'est toujours le même on
s'aperçoit que dans les centres dans les
services bas c'est toujours pareil on
court toujours après le personnel une
première manifestation qui montre que
les pompiers sont bien présents dans les
rues
le 15 octobre les pompiers viendront de
toute la france à paris pour exprimer
leur mécontentement lors on vient d'en
avoir une illustration de plus purement
à certains services publics sont en
grève
comment soutenir ces services qui sont
en manque de moyens et de personnel je
pense y à pas et pas forcément beaucoup
de questions à se poser il avait
notamment sur le call et des pompiers
c'est le département a augmenté les
impôts sont 6 % en 2016 les pompiers
n'en vois pas beaucoup en terme
d'effectif on va pas beaucoup de
résultats de cette augmentation comme le
service public de d'effectifs
on annonce des augmentations d'effectifs
mais qui vont qu'il compense à peine des
baisses dramatiques ont été réalisés
pour 2014 par exemple donc je pense
qu'il faut un geste fort en termes de
recrutement et ce entre les mains du
conseil départemental d'aller dans ce
sens justement nous avons parlé du
département à présent le projet de
fusion yvelines hauts de seine revient
sur le devant de la scène avec cette
information de nos confrères d'europe 1
qui a affirmé mercredi la validation du
projet par emmanuel macron un feu vert
qui auraient été données par le
président de la république au printemps
contacté par notre rédaction le ministre
de la cohésion des territoires dément
l'information tout comme l'elysée
une rencontre à bien
avec les présidents des deux
collectivités les discussions sont
toujours en cours
la décision finale reviendra
effectivement au président de la
république démenti également du
département des hauts-de-seine celui des
yvelines enfin ne souhaite pas commenter
cette information
cette fusion elle serait stratégique
pour aller au m pour s'emparer plus tard
de la région ile de france
c'est le vigan marche on n'est pas
forcément des grands fans du gigantisme
nous on aime bien surtout avant tout que
ce genre de décisions soient prises en
concertation avec les populations
concernées
ce projet de fusion est venue des
conseils départementaux de deux cent et
des yvelines après les élections
départementales
il n'avait pas du tout été question dans
la campagne pour moi c'est ça c'est
grave de ne pas consulter la population
sur selon les choses donc il se fera
avant tout s'il se fait que pense pour
moi avec avec nos consultations avons
toujours su station shell rm on aime
bien consulter la population représente
on se prétend on prétend représenter la
population donc oui il faudra consulter
ouvre une page environnement à présent
le député des yvelines jean noël barrot
organisé ce lundi 16 septembre une
réunion publique à magny les hameaux
la thématique de ce rendez-vous le
projet de loi pour une économie
circulaire et la lutte contre le
gaspillage
une centaine de personnes représentants
d'associations d'élus ou chefs
d'entreprises ont participé aux échanges
nicolas landry il a assisté créer un
indice de réparabilité d'objets
généraliser le logo trimane limiter le
gaspillage des invendus non alimentaires
ou favoriser la consigne plusieurs
dispositions inscrites dans le projet de
loi relatif à la lutte contre le
gaspillage et à l'économie circulaire le
sujet abordé ce lundi 16 septembre dans
une réunion publique organisée par le
député jean noël barrot
je crois que c'est un sujet qui
préoccupe beaucoup les gens les jeunes
d'ailleurs mais toute la société en
général qui souhaite évoluer se donner
des modes de consommation qui sont plus
respectueux de l'environnement et qui
sont plus durables et ça explique l'
enthousiasme qu'on a pu voir s'asseoir
parmi les participants des citoyens des
élus des représentants d'associations
mais aussi les dirigeants d'entreprises
acteurs de l'économie circulaire
c'est le cas de pascal guyot directrice
générale de nouvelles attitudes
cette société basée à buc est
spécialisée dans la collecte et le tri
de papier auprès d'entreprises
10 avec une redistribution à l'industrie
papetière en charge du recyclage
on prend sept ans prend une matière mais
qui est déjà utile et utilisé mon
courrier utilise la matière en produits
et lorsqu'on a consommé on essaye de
réutiliser la matière voilà c'est ça les
commissariats la secrétaire d'état
auprès de la ministre de la transition
écologique brune poirson devait
participer à ce rendez vous elle a été
retenu par une réunion avec la sénatrice
les républicains martha de sidrac
rapporteur du texte
comme tout projet de loi il y aura des
discussions animées entre le sénat et le
gouvernement comme entre l'assemblée
nationale et le gouvernement précisément
parce que c'est un sujet majeur qui
préoccupe tellement les français début
des discussions sur ce texte de loi la
semaine prochaine pour une première
lecture au sénat bien lisse l'économie
circulaire une bonne perspective pour
l'environnement c'est évident à la fois
dans la rue buisson de ce qui est
produit le fait de pouvoir utiliser nous
permet de réduire la consommation de
ressources naturelles ça réduit aussi la
quantité de déchets c'est pour moi
évidemment un axe principal qui va nous
permettre de mettre en place un
développement qui sont plus durables
ce 20 septembre s'est déroulé à paris la
marche pour le climat dans les éviers il
y en aura une scène 10,21 à versailles
et les citoyens se mobilisent pour le
world cleanup day objectif ramasser les
déchets dans une quartier plusieurs
communes et ont déjà participé l'année
dernière à saint quentin en yvelines et
renouvelle l'opération
et parmi elles montigny le bretonneux
avec l'association je respecte ma ville
sa présidente était en plateau du 7-8
loisirs jeudi 19 septembre
c'est la deuxième fois que nous faisons
à montigny le bretonneux
on a commencé l'année dernière avec le
quartier des prés on s'est bien amusé et
cette année on acceptait de le faire
dans les huit quartiers de la ville
notre association a pour but de
sensibiliser au respect du cadre de vie
donc nos terrains d'investigation c'est
l'effet de quartier des fêtes d'école et
fait entreprises mais mais maintenant on
va en maison de retraite
on fait beaucoup d'action justement pour
déjà créer du lien entre les gens et
puis évangéliser pour que la planète est
au profit de notre ville surtout
l'oralair m78 aussi donnent rendez vous
pour le world food day
trapé ali mais ça fait on est encore à
regret tous nos militants à se présenter
sur les événements qui sont organisées
un peu partout dans le département
si on estime que ça fait un peu partie
aussi nous de ce qu'on défend comme
vision comme ils ont du monde c'est des
citoyens qui sont engagés et qui se
mobilisent aussi pour la planète et pour
rassembler plus particulièrement on
organise ces deux événements à 14h
attraper les mines l'écologie c'est ça
fait partie des programmes à l'air om
dans son ensemble jcc transverses à tous
les éléments que l'on pourra proposer
comme comme programme dans toutes nos
villes il ya ce jour pas aucune décision
municipales ou intercommunales qui qui
n'est pas un impact sur l'environnement
et donc on doit absolument défendre une
vision transverse de l'écologie dans
l'île de france et notamment dans les
yvelines ya des problèmes de décharges
sauvages
ça fait partie des sujets auxquels il
faudra s'attaquer ça fait partie des
sujets que l'on adresse dégâts par
exemple natalia pouzet député la 6ème
circonscription est très active sur le
sujet de la déclare que la vallée de la
plaine de plein de garçons précis et
donc c'est c'est un sujet qu'on va avoir
déjà vu qu'en marchon les yvelines notre
truc notre entretien se termine sur ce
rendez-vous bien lieu donc on le
rappelle trappe éliminé samedi demain le
21 septembre
merci de nous avoir accompagnés sur
cette émission merci voulons arrêter à
l'occasion de la semaine de la mobilité
le vix lio s'est installé dans les
yvelines
à la sortie de la gare de saint quentin
en yvelines les wisigoths sont à
disposition pour être essayé et adopté
pendant six mois par de potentiels
d'usagé on vous laisse les découvrir
avec mathilde 2010 le vélo électrique
vélio prend place sur le territoire
notamment à la gare de saint quentin en
yvelines où une station a été aménagé
des futurs usagers qui découvrent ces
vélos bleu toutes équipées avant
d'arriver j'y pensais pas trop parce que
j'ai des enfants est souvent le problème
c est ce que je peux mettre un enfant
sur nos vélos pas effectivement au
moment de la présentation de m'indiquer
la possibilité de mettre un ciel
c'est très bien pensé c'est très bien il
est assez facile il assez simple il ya
trois vitesses pour le mode électrique
et
donc très bien on peut le mettre en vélo
en fonction à la reine vélo complètement
normal électrique pour 40 euros par mois
et une caution de 400 euros
un belgo étaient attribués pendant six
mois un usager pour le stationnement il
peut ramener son vélo chez lui dans une
station vélib ou le laisser dehors mais
risqué de se le faire voler si vous avez
un pavillon vous pouvez avoir la chance
de garder votre vélo facilement voir une
cave
mais quand vous êtes en collectif c'est
beaucoup plus compliqué et que dans les
collectifs déjà même les vélos
électriques se font parfois volé et
settat et c'est un frein du coup au
développement du vélo pour tout le monde
en attendant des locaux à vélo plus
sécurisé pour éviter tout risque de
casse et de vol les pistes cyclables
pourront être prises d'assaut par ces
nouveaux vélos électriques qui ne
demande qu'à rouler et ce week-end ont
lieu les 36e journée du patrimoine
journées européennes du patrimoine pour
l'occasion aurélie ronces vous a préparé
une sélection en images et en musique
des sites yvelinois qui ouvrent leurs
portes au public
[Musique]
et n'hésitez pas à visionner nos
émissions 7,8 culture et 7,8 choisir au
replay pour une étendue du programme sur
notre site internet du sport désormais
les féminines du club de basket au
chesnay versailles renoue avec la
nationale 2 samedi dernier elles ont
remporté leur premier match de la saison
à l'extérieur durant l'intersaison
quelques changements trois départs pour
trois recrues prochain match ce samedi
21 septembre à 20 heures au gymnase bel
air au généreux concours on écoute leurs
cochons micro de nicolas landry on va
continuer notre travail de l'année
dernière on va se baser sur notre
défense et on va essayer de jouer avec
beaucoup de contre attaques comme on
vient de monter de nationale 3 une
nouvelle équipe avec trois nouvelles
choses
il faut qu'elle s'adapte le maintien
c'est notre objectif
[Musique]
et c'est un fléau qui agace de plus en
plus
habitants et élus les décharges sauvages
assagi dans le val d'oise des mesures
sont prises
reportage de nico et michael joly de nos
confrères via grand paris des gravats
des planches des déchets végétaux
nous ne sommes pas dans une décharge
mais aux abords d'un champ situé dans le
vexin assagi une commune rurale qui voit
régulièrement ces chanceux transformées
en décharges sauvages
de quoi exaspérer le maire de la ville
qui a bien du mal à lutter contre le
phénomène
on avait la même chose juste en face sur
le terrain qui est en face le chemin qui
est en fait comme on a mis des blocs de
pierres pour empêcher de circuler sur
chemins le camion qui est venu bas il
s'est dit tiens il ya un autre chemin un
peu plus loin je vais m'engager et voilà
il a versé en deux opérations c'est de
ces deux camions voir nos paysages
polluée par des dépôts de ce genre c'est
inadmissible et intolérable si l'abandon
de déchets dans la nature est puni par
la loi
les gendarmes du val d'oise constate une
augmentation du phénomène ces derniers
mois pour la zone gendarmerie du val
d'oise à l'heure actuelle nous avons
constaté 280 dépôts sauvages qu'on a
constaté effectivement une augmentation
de la volumétrie de dépôts sauvages sur
le secteur qui est corrélé aux effets
effectivement de grandes constructions
de la plaque parisienne et des
comportements déviants quand on continue
d'observer de quoi également inquiété le
nouveau préfet du département qui ont
ans est acquis au problème avec de
nouvelles mesures l'état donc à décider
désormais d'intervenir pour aider les
communes rurales à se doter
d'équipements qui nous allons donc
prendre en charge 50 % des barriérage au
travers d'une dotation dont qui existent
le fonds interministériel portant sur la
délinquance
la dotation donc également d' indignés
qui vient soutenir donc l'initiative
locale la des cils pourra intervenir
pour l'enlèvement des gravats
c'est une première donc au niveau
départemental ici à sagy j'ai le plaisir
de vous dire c'est aussi une première au
niveau national d'autres mesures
devraient également être mises en place
dans les prochaines années les
fabricants de matériaux de construction
pourraient notamment être tenu
responsable du recyclage de leurs
produits
ils devront mettre en place des filières
de recyclage c'est la fin de cette
édition merci de nous avoir suivi on se
quitte avec des images de nourrir cette
jeune maurepas
vienne dont vous pouvez suivre laventure
dans the voice kid prochain rendez vous
avec l'information locale lundi avec le
7-8 journal pour ricaine sur tv 78
[Musique]
oh